can I start by welcoming the new member
of parliament for the city of Chester
[Applause]
result for labor in the 105 years we've
been fighting that seat and I look
forward to working with her to build a
better future for the people of Chester
[Music]
a thousand houses a year this week
without asking a single voter the Prime
Minister broke that Promise by scrapping
mandatory targets
what changed
Mr Speaker let me start by also
welcoming The Honorable lady to her to
her place now The Honorable gentleman
comes here every week and I know he's
focused on the process and the politics
but I don't think he's actually taken
the time to read the detail of what we
are doing to improve our
let me let me just explain what we are
doing we are Mr Speaker we are
protecting the green belt
testing Millions to develop Brownfield
sites and we're providing support and
protection for local neighborhood plans
no housing secretary said she said
Community should have control over where
homes were built and what sort of homes
are built that's my position that's her
position what's his position
[Applause]
does he really expect us to believe that
the member for chipping Barton and the
member for the Isle of Wight are
cheering him on because he's going to
build more homes pull the other one
I'll tell him I'll tell him what changed
his back benches threatened him and as
always the blancmange Prime Minister
wobbled
heat is a grubby deal with a handful of
his MPS and sold out the aspirations of
those who want to own their own home was
it worth it
Mr Speaker as ever as ever engaging in
the petty personality politics
not not not not not focused on the
substance again let me explain what
we're doing we're delivering what I said
we would do we're protecting the
character of local communities
we're cracking down on land banking an
irresponsible Developers
we're giving people a greater say in
their decisions just this week Mr
Speaker just this week on Monday The
Honorable gentleman said the government
should be giving people more power and
control
[Applause]
now now he seems to be opposing that
policy it's only Wednesday I know he
flip-flops but even for him it's pretty
quick
Mr Speaker he's forgotten last week
last week I offered him labor votes to
pass these housing targets because this
is bigger than politics the former
housing secretary on their side said
scrapping mandatory targets would this
is his words from their side of the
house be a colossal failure of political
leadership no wonder he doesn't want to
fight the next election Mr Speaker the
author of the manifesto that they all
stood on said it would cut building by
40 percent
more why would he rather [ __ ] house
building than work with us
to get those targets through
[Applause]
in London in London the form in London
the former conservative mayor in five
years built sixty thousand affordable
homes
the current labor mayor half of that
amount
in Wales in Wales We Want to Build 12
000 homes what a labor delivering half
of that Mr Speaker
the labor party talks the conservatives
deliver
[Applause]
as ever too weak to stand up to his own
side of this
I I noticed there was another U-turn
last night this time on wind farms
actually I agree with that one but it's
the no issue on which he won't give in
to his back benches
now Mr Speaker how did his colleague
baroness moan end up with nearly 30
million pounds of taxpayers money in her
bank account
Mr Speaker let me say like everyone else
I was absolutely shocked to read about
the allegations
it's absolutely right
[Applause]
it's it's absolutely it's absolutely
right that she is no longer attending
the House of Lords and therefore no
longer has the conservative whip that
again the one thing we know about Donald
gentleman he is a lawyer he should know
there's a process in place
it's right that that process concludes I
hope that it's resolved promptly but I
say one thing Mr Speaker because it I'll
tell him he mentioned I'll tell him what
is weak I tell him what is weak it's not
being able to I'll tell him and that's
not being able to stand up to people
just wait I know he's taken some advice
from Gordon Brown lately
why doesn't why
why to a former minister in Gordon
Brown's government who just said why
does the labor party refuse to stand up
for workers and businesses like pubs and
restaurants who will lose business as a
result of the train strikes labor should
stand up for working people if he's
strong that's what he should do
yeah
Mr Speaker it may not seem like it but
he's supposed to be the Prime Minister
this morning this morning his transport
secretary said that his Flagship
legislation on strikes this is what he
said this morning his transport
secretary might want to listen to this
is clearly
clearly clearly not going to help with
the industrial action we're facing he
should stop grandstanding stop sitting
on his hands get around the table and
resolve these issues and everyone can
see what's happening here a Tory
politician got their hands on hundreds
of millions in taxpayers money and then
provided Duff PPE and he says he's
shocked he was the chancellor he he
signed the checks
how much is he gonna get back
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker it's right that he brought up
legislation with regard to strikes I'm
very happy to address it actually so
hard-working families right now in this
country are facing challenges the
government has been reasonable it's a
it says it's higher than the private
sector but if the union leaders to
continue to be unreasonable then it is
my duty to take action to protect the
lives and livelihoods of the British
public and that's why Mr Speaker since I
became prime minister I have been
working for new tough laws to protect
people from this disruption that's the
legislation he's asking about will he
now confirm that he'll stand up for
working people and that he and his party
will back that legislation
Mr Speaker he's obviously he's obviously
not heard what is transport secretary
said about that legislation this morning
and it's obvious why they're so opposed
to Labor's plans to clean up Westminster
they all voted for tax Rises for working
people while one of their unelected
peers pocketed Millions flogging dodgy
PPE should be change now Mr Speaker I
want to raise something that is worrying
parents across the country
Hearts our hearts go out
children who've tragically died from the
outbreak of strep a in recent weeks I'm
very happy to work with the government
on this
so can he take the opportunity to update
the country on the measures the country
is taking to keep children safe this
winter
well Mr Speaker my thoughts were of
course with the families of the children
who have sadly lost their lives we are
seeing a higher number of cases from
strepe this year compared to usual uh
what I can say is that the NHS who I've
sat down to talk about this are working
very hard to make sure parents are aware
of the symptoms that they should be
looking out to because this can be
treated appropriately with the
antibiotics there are no current
shortages of drugs available to treat
this and they're well-established
procedures in place to ensure that that
remains the case and the uksha are
monitoring the situation at PACE and
what they have confirmed is that there
is this is not a new strain of strep a
so people should be reassured about that
there is no reason to believe that it's
become more lethal a more resistant to
antibiotics so the most important thing
for parents to do is look out for the
symptoms and get the treatment that is
available for them